did you know that one in five teenagers
has a serious mental illness or the
mental illness has been linked to
substance abuse and suicide and
teenagers mental health disorders like
depression and anxiety are among the
most serious problems facing our society
today in order for us to better diagnose
and treat mental illness we first must
understand what it looks like in the
brain and that's what we're setting up
to do we are the Boston adolescent
neuroimaging of depression and anxiety
consortium or abanda for short banda
uses non-invasive state-of-the-art brain
imaging to identify brain markers of
anxiety and depression and teenagers
right now it takes an average of nine
years before teenagers start treatment
for mental illness at Vanda we believe
that these brain markers will help us
identify teens at risk for anxiety and
depression much sooner and hopefully
improve the way we treat mental illness
all together to learn more or to join
our team brain project visit us at banda
MIT edu